hi there today we'll look at gradient
origin networks by sam von taylor
and chris g wilcox of durham university
so on a high level this paper trains
implicit representation networks
but not on single data points but on
entire data set
it does so by using a latent encoding of
each data point
and it doesn't obtain that encoding
through an explicit
encoder but by simply looking at the
gradient of the latent
variable with when initialized at the
origin
so it's a bit of a weird formulation and
i've seen this paper uh upvoted on
reddit
and the top comments would also would
always say like i don't really get it i
don't really get it
and i thought you know maybe i'm
completely wrong but
i can just give my opinion kind of
what's going on
in this paper now also most people on
reddit or a lot did
say i don't really get it but here is
what i think
is going on and then listing something
and that's there's where i
i stopped reading so as to not be kind
of as to form my own opinion i like to
kind of understand papers uh by myself
so
again maybe i'm completely wrong but
here is
my opinion if you like opinions
uh hit the like button and subscribe if
you
aren't yet and uh yeah share this video
out
maybe that helps someone else understand
so this paper
is a very short paper it is four pages
and um it's a dense paper it definitely
can warrant um it definitely can warrant
making
a longer paper out of it though that
being said it's on archive paper
for now uh so you know there's nothing
wrong with
archiving kind of unfinished work
but we'll just gonna look at it and try
to understand it
okay so the abstract says this paper
proposes
a new type of implicit generative model
that is able to quickly learn a latent
representation without an
explicit encoder so
for that you need to know what an
implicit generative model is
and i've covered one type of implicit
generative model specifically
the type that they're using here what
they're called siren
so sirens are implicit representation
networks and i've made a video about
sirens so if you don't know what that is
go look it up but very quickly
a siren will is a neural network to
represent
a single data point so each data point
in a data set
is represented by its own neural network
and the neural network so this might be
a bit foreign to you
but usually you have some kind of image
right and it's simply
represented as an as an array of rgb
coordinates right it's
it's simply an array of it says like 1 0
0.5 and so on so all the pixels are in
this array this is the explicit
representation
of that data point now this here is a
long list
and it has some regularities to it so
that's why
you can also think of an implicit
representation of the data point the
implicit representation works as follows
you imagine again your image your image
is made up
of pixels and these pixels are on x and
y coordinates
so this pixel right here would be 0 0
this pixel right here would be 0
1 and so on yes a siren
is or a generally an implicit
representation network is a network that
takes in
any x and y coordinate as the input so
the input itself
is the numerical x and y coordinate of
that picture
and it passes it through a neural
network and out comes the rgb
value okay and so
an entire picture is represented by this
neural network
the neural network maps each coordinate
to its rgb value
and here you can see that the in this
single a single picture can become
an entire data set for this neural
network in fact it has to
because for a different picture of
course there is a different mapping from
x and y coordinates to
rgb coordinates but this allows you to
do multiple things so first of all this
neural network can be
smaller than the explicit representation
second of all you can capture some
regularity in the data specifically
sirens have uh sine waves as
non-linearities in the in the neural
network here
which is also a bit special but lends
itself very well to
capture natural signals because um
natural signals are often
you know repeated at different scales
and derivatives of themselves and so on
so
i've covered this all in my in my video
and also this allows you to have a
continuous representation rather than a
discrete representation like here you
just have each pixel
now you have a a continuous
representation
all right so these are implicit
representation models or
implicit generative models are these
neural networks
right here that map from coordinates to
two colors now what's the problem with
this is as we said you need
one neural network per data point
now the idea that these
people here go with is that can't we do
kind of the same thing but except we
have one neural network per data point
we want to have the same neural network
for the entire data
set so again they want to have a neural
network
that somehow outputs rgb coordinates
but now it's not for a single image now
we have a data
set okay and the data set has many
images like this is
image i this is image j this is image
k so what we could do is we could simply
uh tell the neural network the x and y
coordinate that we
where we would like the rgb values to
know
and we could also tell it which image it
is right k
or i or j and
this will give us a neural network right
here
that can represent the entire data set
because it always can see ah i want
of image j i want these these x y
coordinate doesn't help you very much
though
because it still has to learn for each
image individually
how to encode it how to produce it
what's much more interesting is
if you kind of mix this with the kind of
old style
the kind of old style generative model
so in old style generative models
let's consider for example an auto
encoder so in an auto encoder
what you would do is you would take your
image and you would put it through
an encoder and this encoder will give
you
a latent variable z and then you would
put it through a decoder again
and that would give you an image so
your generative model now is this part
right here
and this z variable is your latent
encoding of this data point
now if you train these models correctly
be this
a be this a an autoencoder or
a variational autoencoder or the green
part can actually just be
a gan right if you train this correctly
then this z right here will be sort of
a a latent encoding
of the what the what of the information
in the image itself okay
and that can generalize so now i can
input
a picture that the model has never seen
during training
and the encoder will map it to a latent
representation
that sort of makes sense that is able to
reconstruct
the image that i've put in okay so
the your hope with these latent
representation is is that there is some
kind of data manifold somewhere
in hidden in the in the entire space
of uh parameters and as long as you're
on that data manifold
you will produce a sensible data point
and this is kind of a continuous and so
on
so even though you've only seen a few
during training
if you have a new one during testing
then you can sort of it will be
mapped to a correct place on the data
manifold and it will produce a data
point again
and you've seen this right you've seen
these interpolations in gans where you
can
interpolate in latent space and and so
on
the problem here is that you know in so
in gans we sample
these things right here so that's a
different story but in vaes
we need this encoder or in auto encoders
we need this encoder
to obtain a latent representation for a
given data point
in gans there is no way if we have an
image there is no way to obtain the
corresponding
z variable if we don't have an encoder
right and that's the the problem we're
tackling right here so
here what we want to do is we want to
give the x and y we want to give the z
we we say we have some way of obtaining
a latent representation
of one of the image right here and from
that we want to generate the rgb
variables now the question is
think of again the question is how do we
obtain
the z variable without having
without having access to the encoder
and that's that's the problem of this
paper and this paper
proposes a solution
so they say this is achieved
with an implicit neural network that
takes as inputs points in the coordinate
space
alongside a latent vector initialized
with zero so that's the model that we
saw
that's this this is sorry about that
this is this right here it takes in
the coordinates this is the coordinates
and it takes in the
latent vector z now
this whole point with it being
initialized at zeros we'll get
we'll get to that in one second okay
for the fact right now is just that the
represent the
implicit neural network also takes the
identity of the image so
each image the image is always going to
have the same z
and then we sort of say which x and y
coordinate of that image we want so the
z is per image
and then each image has all the x and y
coordinates of
you know itself so yeah
so if yeah you you i think you can
follow
they go on they say the gradients of the
data fitting loss with respect to this
zero vector are jointly optimized to act
as latent points that capture the data
manifold
so this is where this is where i already
got lost
reading the first time through the
results show similar characteristics to
auto encoders but with fewer parameters
and the advantages of implicit
representation
networks okay so we'll actually we'll
we'll jump to this right here so this is
the
this is the comparison between a
variational auto encoder
and the gradient origin network so in a
what you would do is you would have this
explicit
encoder right here as we said and in the
variational auto encoder you don't
obtain the latent representation
directly you actually obtain
the distribution in terms of the mean
and standard deviation of the latent
representation and then you sample
from that distribution to obtain that
latent representation i think the point
here is simply to show that
you first of all you do need an encoder
which you do need to train and second of
all it's kind of a complicated process
to get that latent representation for
the data point x
and then you need the decoder that
generates an image and then you have
the loss right here that compares the
two
that is used to train the encoder and
the decoder
whereas in the gradient origin networks
what you do is you start you basically
have a function f
and the function f it's a bit
it's a bit weird right here the function
f uses two things
so this here is that z uh which is
termed zero here but in fact it's the
latent representation
of the image which is derived from the
image itself
and i don't really know so i guess you
can
here you can input this x it's derived
from the image itself by
some way that doesn't require parameters
that is not learned
and it also takes in these coordinates
and it produces that image now let's
disentangle two things right here
what we're going to see um is equally
applicable to non-implicit neural
networks
so for the rest of this paper now i'm
not saying it's going to work as well
maybe it's going to work specifically
well with implicit neural networks
but we need to differentiate the these
two
things so the first thing is explicit
versus
implicit okay
we're simply going to view these as
functions that take
a z and give you an x okay
if this is this is most notably the
explicit version the implicit version
is simply that we're going to take a z
along with all the
x and y of the image and we're going to
obtain
the r g and b values of all
the images right which is equal to the x
um so this this entire set of rgb values
is equal to the x and we input the
entire set right here
but essentially it's simply a function
that takes in
a latent uh representation of an image
and gives you back a image
the second thing which is an entirely
different thing in my opinion
is how do we obtain a z from an
x so how do we get to have an image
how do we obtain the corresponding
latent representation
and such that such that
so this must be such that
this function right here the function
that gives you the x from the z
will reproduce the x okay
so how do we obtain the correct latent
representation
for any for any um input data points
two different things don't so
i think they're not dependent on each
other except
as i said they might work especially
well together or something like this
all right so this becomes a lot easier
right now
in this formula so this is the thing
ultimately that they optimize
they optimize the this thing and it's
introduced
like i don't know why they limited
themselves to four pages here and again
this is work in progress as i understand
it but
it is it is not it's like cold water
it's like
um you know an expressive neural network
can be trained in this space to mimic
this by minimizing the gradient origin
network loss function that's
that's it that's what you that's what
you get and then you get the loss thrown
in your face
well let's deconstruct it so this g
thing right here what's it uh
this is the loss that you minimize okay
you can see
that this is simply an integral of this
loss function
over your entire coordinate space so c
here is the entire coordinate space
so this is for a given for a given image
right for a given image f x you would
minimize this actually
across your across your entire data set
so you would minimize
the parameters of f f here is going to
be
your generator neural network your siren
whatever
you minimize over the parameters of f
across your entire data set okay so this
is your
standard loss function that is a sum
across your entire data set
cool so what are you going to minimize
you're going to minimize each data point
consists of an integral
over the coordinate space which you
can't see
of this loss function right here now
this is simply due to the fact that this
is an implicit representation
if this were an explicit representation
it would simply be
the loss function of that data point
okay
um so don't don't be scared by the
integral i'm usually scared by integrals
i never get them and then i try to talk
to them and be people be like
do you think you know riemannian
integral or a lubig
integral and i'm like okay
but in in this case um this is this
simply means that
you want the loss of each of the
coordinates and you want to sum
them up right which is the same as
simply
the uh the normal loss function with
respect to a data point
this right here is the data point
itself as you can see this is
the this is your natural signal so
this is the function that you don't know
this is the true image function that
maps the
coordinates to the rgb space
in the case of explicit representation
this here
is simply x okay and
forget about this integral for now
cool so we have a loss between x
and whatever this is right here
ah this is a bit too long and whatever
this is right here you can see
the loss function between two things so
what is this thing the loss function i
can tell you the one they use in this
particular paper is the l2 loss so this
is simply the reconstruction loss
between a data point and it's
its reconstruction okay so this part on
the right is what's going to make the
reconstruction
you can see yes our f here is going to
be our siren our
neural network that will take in a z
so f is one of these function explicit
or implicit that takes in a z
and gives you x at the the
reconstruction
now the question is what does f take
in um f takes in
two things first of all the coordinates
concatenated with the thing on the right
and you remember
we said that instead of giving x
y to the implicit representation we now
give x y
and z where z is the latent vector of
the image we're trying to
reconstruct so if we were to see
this as a non-implicit method
we can simply leave away this right so
we
as we leave away the x and y coordinates
in a
in a gan or a va we simply give it this
thing right here again we're trying to
disentangle the implicit
um network the implicit generator
from how we are going to obtain the z
so this is not important so what remains
is this quantity
right here so this must be
our z for the image okay
this thing so what's this thing
um i'm running slowly out of colors
this thing is going to be somehow the
negative gradient of something again
you have the integral right here of the
loss function this
again is x this here again we can leave
this away
we can leave away the integral and
you'll start to see
kind of a repetitive thing um so
this is going to be the gradient somehow
of your loss function
um with that again
there is x and then there is f of z
zero so this is somehow an x t an x hat
as well
but this is a special x hat let's call
it x hat prime
or x hat zero because the input is not
z but the input is now z zero
okay this is kind of a complicated
thing so i'm going to explain what's
going on
right here um maybe in drawing
so what you want to do is you want to
start out with z0
which is an initial guess of what your
latent representation is you do it
without looking even
at the image without the data point you
simply start with one
and there are multiple ways to do this
and
this paper right here simply says we're
going to
d0 is just going to be a constant value
zero the constant value 0. that's why
it's called gradient origin networks
because you always start with your z 0
your initial guess of your latent
representation
is the origin okay then
you use f your neural network to obtain
a estimate a first estimate of what your
image could look like again you have not
looked at the image you're simply taking
the z
zero and you produce an image
then you somehow
somehow obtain a better representation z
and that you use your f
again to obtain x hat and then
from that x hat you can now compare this
to your x and that will give you your
loss that you back propagate
so two things here um you can see you
use
f twice which means that your loss if
you back propagated you must somehow
back
propagate to both of these things okay
so this is the first
the first thing if you back propagate
the second thing is
what's this thing right here how are we
going to
obtain somehow a better z and
the better z is going to be obtained by
uh basically looking at the gradient so
you've seen
that we have a gradient of z zero of the
loss
of um x and
f of z zero
that's that thing here is going to be
your z z equals
that what does it mean it basically
means that
so you've tried to produce an image
but this is the real image that you want
to get and the loss measures
how far apart you are from that real
image
how would you need to change your
initial guess in order to make that loss
go down
so the negative here is to make the loss
go down because
otherwise it make the loss go up okay so
it basically simply says
how do you need to change your z zero
in order to decrease the loss in order
to get a
better z for representing this
particular image
right here and in the paper
here is where i kind of disagree
because in the paper they say that they
that this
in a single step they give this gives
you
a um this gives you the correct
z or something like this and i don't
i don't agree they say
with respect to the origin we obtain a
latent vector that minimizes the
reconstruction loss
is obtained in a single step thereby
playing the similar role to an explicit
encoder
so this is true this is kind of like an
encoder right you simply ask what
z would i need to put in in order to
make this representation
be a better sorry in order to make the
latent representation be a better latent
representation
for the particular image x however
if you compare so what is this this is
essentially
gradient descent in the latent space
right
and the fact that we look at the
explicit gradient is only because they
started
at the zero point right here the fact
that they started at the zero point
means that here they can just leave away
the following what if you were to do
gradient descent what you would do
is you would say this my z is going to
be equal to
z 0 minus this thing right now it looks
much more like
gradient descent in the latent space
because
you have some initial guess and then you
update it using the gradient
now there is no learning rate right here
so the learning rate is one
in this case um so this is
and again the z zero because it's
zero you can just leave it away so this
is simply
one single step of gradient descent
in the latent space
in order to get a better z right here
however this is not a this is doesn't it
it doesn't guarantee you that in this
single step you're actually going to
find
the correct z or even an appropriate z
it simply means that you're going to
find
a better z than z zero
um for that particular image and this
can work
right um and again because you back
propagate to both of the f's
you say you basically say i want my
neural network first of all to
reconstruct
the data point better from a given
latent representation and i also want my
neural network
to give me a latent representation
basically to help my latent to help this
procedure
you back propagate through the gradient
descent procedure
so you say i want my neural network to
help me obtain a better latent
representation
if i do one step of gradient descent
so therefore it's not just pure gradient
descent in that space it actually
the back propagation makes it such that
your neural network
also supports that supports obtaining
a good representation in one step
okay now that we've disentangled this
basically
you can see two things first of all you
could probably get an even better
representation by doing multiple steps
of gradient descent
right here maybe adjusting the learning
rate a bit
it depends right because you have to
back propagate through all the gradient
descent steps
but pretty sure you could probably
improve this by doing multiple
steps second of all it doesn't really
matter
that this is a constant zero uh it gives
you know
there's a cool name gradient origin
networks but you could probably start
with
any um constant or even here's the thing
even
non-constant initial points you could
sample them
from a distribution and so on and okay
so
let's change like let's imagine changing
z
zero to be sampled from some normal
distribution
and then it looks much more like a gan
right
all right so here we go i've cloned the
repo and i've
ran the code once just to make sure that
the data is downloaded and everything
and the code is you know pretty pretty
easy
so there is one file and i didn't do it
in the cola because the collapse was i
think a bit
slow for me i don't know if i've caught
a wrong
runtime but essentially there is a bunch
of
setup code they know this siren layers
and so on
and then you have the real deal um
thing right here so you have a step so
we do 500
steps and in each step we as you can see
right here we start with
zeros as z then we put this into f
concatenated with the coordinates so the
coordinates is like a kind of a mesh
grid
type thing we obtain the inner
loss right here we do a gradient
with respect so of the inner loss with
respect to z
and then the negative gradient that's
going to become our outer z
so this z up here is z zero and this z
down here is going to be our true z
from the paper we are going to
concatenate that again
with the coordinates to obtain the g
which is the kind of reconstruction of x
and then our outer loss is going to be
simply this reconstruction loss right
here and then we're going to backward
to all of the parameters okay so
first hypothesis is that this here
is simply kind of gradient descent so
what we should be able to do is
first let's run let's run this so i've
run this
um like that
so this is shipping it to a gpu server
and as you will be able to see
the loss will be output
and it's going to kind of decrease the
loss over the
course of 500 steps and we can also look
at
the samples
so while that's happening what we can do
is we can actually
already prepare what we want to do so if
this is really gradient descent we
should be
basically just able to do this z minus
this gradient right here because it's
zeros uh we would simply expect this to
yield the same loss so we're going to do
this
and then we're going to ship this off to
the
server again oh sorry um
so we're we were here and okay
uh the logs failed
all right so uh this is called images
i i have this thing set up such that um
it's called logs but you can basically
see that the
loss right here was from 24 going to
down to about
13 or so over the course of training so
by
subtracting z minus
uh the gradient we there really
shouldn't be any change
right because z is zero at the beginning
so again we're going to run this and
while it's running
we're going to prepare um
[Music]
the different things so my hypothesis is
that we can maybe we could
make this z here pretty much anything so
let's do it let's put it into ones
again you see that the loss i guess
you know we get an idea of kind of the
noisiness of this thing
and 21 19 and so on
we can in fact over here we might be
able to
if we ship it to a different gpu might
be able to run two things in parallel so
this now
is when we just start with ones instead
of
zeros
so let's see how that happens well
that's the case
so you can see right here that we ended
up at
also about 14 13. uh
this pretty much is the same if you you
can we can look at the
images that it's produced so the
reconstructions look
kind of like this a fashion mnist these
samples
kind of look like this
and the interval interpolations you can
look at those as well
but we're mainly interested also in the
in the kind of loss right here
you can see that with the ones pretty
much the same thing is happening
so let's say we actually change this to
a
normal distribution okay
what does that do and while that's
happening we're going to
revert this to the original zeros
and we're going to investigate what
happens if we just do more than one step
of gradient
descent so in order to do that it's
actually pretty easy so
this here is the gradient descent step
what we can do is we can simply
double that right so now if this
is correct i'm pretty sure this is
correct okay the
so the normal initialized isn't
really the the hit right here as you can
see the
wow okay um the normal
isn't uh maybe it's because it's you
know
too large um
i'm not sure i mean the other thing is
deterministic so that's going to be
like a lot easier uh we can quickly go
back
and let's go
uh once let's go to normal
and let's like multiply it
with like a tiny like uh 0.01 or so
i just want to see whether this works i
have no big hopes
okay so we are here again and we're
going to make this
into two different things
two steps of gradient descent
all right so now we have two steps of
gradient descent
and let's see whether that helps ah
okay so the normal distribution already
helps uh or is not worse
we we simply initialized it with uh too
big of a a variance
the point zero one seems to be some kind
of magic number for normal distributions
and neural networks
so on the right side over here and you
can see we're a bit
we're a bit it's a bit off but i guess
with a bit of tuning you could do
that and it gets down to about the same
loss
as you saw if we look at the images that
this produced
i'm going to guess it's you know they
seem a bit worse
but it kind of works on the right side
however if you do more than one step of
gradient descent
you see we already start at lower losses
and
since this is gradient descent we can
also you know there's no need why the
learning rate should be one so let's
try to divide it by
a generous three and then
by maybe you know it's a six like a
decreasing learning rate seems like a
rather good idea and
yeah let's just take the two steps with
the decreasing learning rate oops
so you can see that the loss now is way
down
just because we did two steps of
gradient descent and the reconstructions
i'm going to guess they're almost perp
so we're now
i guess we're overfitting a bit so this
is now trading off kind of power of the
encoder decoder and so on
um but ultimately yeah so let's just for
the last part
just try to um have this gradient
descent with the decreasing
step size and see where that gets us if
that gets us to even
a lower reconstruction loss um
and that will be our investigation into
the code right here
uh okay
okay we start with 19
maybe we're we're as good as before
that's fine
you know um but i hope i hope that kind
of
uh gives a bit of evidence to my point
that this
is basically reversing a generator
by using gradient descent which has been
around for a while
and i happen to know someone who
who once attempted then to write a paper
about it
so yeah but it's it's with implicit
networks which are pretty cool so
you know maybe this might work
especially well with them given that the
gradient of a siren is a gradient
and ah it's a siren and so on
yep as you can see this works as well
decreasing learning rate and now
you can go nuts oh nine wow this is the
lowest loss we've gotten so far right
yeah so pretty cool
reconstructions look like things
well these are the best samples i think
these are the best samples we've seen
today
maybe not i'm not sure let's look at the
interpolations quickly
yeah this looks like interpolations
i mean if he squint okay this was it for
coding
see ya um now
gans have come with encoders before
or it much more looks like a variational
auto autoencoder as well
the difference here is we we replace the
encoder so this here
is our encoder right this is
our implicit encoder is simply gradient
descent
this has also been done before for gans
so people train gans and then they try
to find the latent representation by
back propagating and some people even do
this
while um some people do this
while training they do gradient and then
either do or do not back prop through
the gan
um through the gradient resent procedure
so in a way or another this
is kind of um sort of
like those ideas not saying it is equal
and again there could be like some
special
interaction because you actually back
prop through both these things and there
could be some special interaction
because
this are implicit neural networks
however i very much
view these as two different things um
the cool
there is a rather cool derivation of
that
where you can say okay you can also use
it as a classifier by basically
doing this and now i hope you can
understand this
much better so what we'll have is we'll
have the classification
loss for sample x is going to be your
cross entropy loss between two things
okay well can you please go down again
thanks so um your cross
your loss between two things is going to
be the loss between your label y
so that's one thing and usually you have
the feature the logits on this side
right now you can see right here you
have an
f that's probably that something that
gives you the logits
from your features and here your
features aren't going to be
at the data point itself but your
features are going to be
the z variable that comes with the data
point so basically you use this
as a feature producer and the feature
producer is
made by again minimizing this
reconstruction loss
now i'm not sure this is going to work
really well for classifiers because
classifiers
generally don't require you to
reconstruct things
and we know this you know people try to
this is like you were to
have a variational auto encoder and then
simply use that encoder as a feature
producer for a classifier
which generally doesn't work very well
but you know you can you can do it
right here and the the cool thing is
that you can actually use the implicit
representation network f
to give you features for the entire data
uh sample z so you you're kind of
freed from the coordinate representation
here and you get kind of a latent
um a latent vector back so this is how
you would use an implicit
neural network in order to do
classification
that's i think you know pretty pretty
cool um derivation of this
so here they make some empirical claims
which
i don't i don't want to go too much into
but there are
certain advantages certain practical
advantages of doing things like this
like you can have very very few
parameters to represent
an entire uh set of data the
interpolations here work nicely
as you can see and i think generally
they make the claim that this trains
fast
and you can see after three seconds it
already has a lot of information about
the data set
and it does some sensible things
okay so the code is available
and in fact i'll probably inter
inter parse into this video
a let's actually test our hypotheses
right let's test these hypotheses that i
said so first hypothesis is probably
we can start with something else than
the constant zero and second hypothesis
we can probably improve by doing
multiple steps of gradient descent in
the
inner loop yes i this might be somewhere
in this video
and if not it comes at the end like
right now
okay so i'll see you next time bye bye